with a full roster of spooky ghosts and
a literal room full of references
Annabel comes home is stuffed with small
details as opposed to the original
Annabelle doll which is only stuffed
with cotton or whatever old Raggedy Ann
dolls were stuffed with fiberglass maybe
that's why everyone's so scared to touch
it
it's devilishly itchy I'm not gonna
touch the doll I'm not gonna touch it
call the babysitter because we're diving
deep into all the small details in
Annabel comes home and we're conjuring
up plenty of spoilers along the way
right at the beginning Annabel comes
home puts viewers on familiar ground if
you didn't notice the story picks up
right where we first met Annabel all
those years ago
in 2013's the conjuring that film starts
with the porcelain poltergeist
terrorizing some girls in an apartment
before the Warrens step in to take that
mean all doll off their hands Annabel
comes home opens on a continuation of
that scene which both grounds the story
for longtime fans and gives it a firm
chronological place in the conjuring
universe of course we also get a little
insight into why the Warrens are so
scared of Annabel since the doll decides
to bring half a cemetery back to life to
terrorize the couple on the drive home
geez Annabel can't you even chill for
one night
honey okay the one place you never want
to go in the Warrens house is into the
artifact room that door has 18 locks on
it for a reason there's nothing on the
other side but unimaginable horror
prepare to enter the scary door
at least that's true in the film world
for viewers the artifact room is
undoubtedly a treasure trove of Easter
eggs and references there we can see the
music box from the first conjuring right
where ed left it at the end of the film
there are also items that haven't shown
up in the conjuring world but are taken
from the real world instead the book the
black shuck alludes to a mythical ghost
dog that supposedly roams the English
countryside and the ferryman is a figure
in multiple mythologies in Greek
mythology he was a dude named Karen who
ferried Souls across the river Styx for
a fee you like dead people right I got a
few dead people you might recognize
check this out Jackson grant and look
who's joining the party Benjamin
Franklin like a teenage girl with a
crush or a mailman Annabelle is a big
fan of leaving notes specifically she
leaves notes with the spooky question
miss me when she's in the throes of
haunting the living daylights out of
someone this little detail goes all the
way back to the first conjuring film in
that intro sequence the girls find the
message scrawled in red crayon on a
crumpled piece of paper in Annabelle
comes home the motif shows up in several
different places notably on the Haunted
typewriter in the Warrens artifact room
also worth mentioning is that the
repetition and the use of the typewriter
is reminiscent of Jack Torrance's
Alworth and no play makes Jack a dull
boy
typewriter breakdown in the shining that
may or may not have been intentional but
it's a nice nod to a horror classic if
it was one of the Easter eggs and
Annabel comes home happens early in the
movie when Mary Ellen is in the
supermarket she runs into her friend
Daniella and the two stop in front of a
rack of comic books they were only on
screen for a second but the specific
comics really say a lot first of all
they're all DC comics no big surprise
there the Annabelle films are owned by
Warner Brothers which also owns the DC
extended universe you can catch the
cover of a detective comics issue as
well as an issue of strange adventures
starring the world's most super-powered
archaeologist Adam Strange beware the
Jubjub
and shun the frumious Bandersnatch got
your nose but most fittingly Annabel
comes home director Gary Doberman
revealed that there's also a Swamp Thing
comic on the rack for those who don't
know Doberman also co-created the DC
series Swamp Thing which was sadly
cancelled before the entire first season
could even finish airing Ed Warren was a
man of many talents he was an author a
public speaker a ghost chaser and on top
of it all he was really good at
convincing people to pay him for all
these things but fewer people know that
he was also essentially the bob ross of
haunted houses at building a building
looks as old as me and that's always
Eddy's paintings have shown up in
conjuring films before at least
fictionalized versions have the one most
fans know about is the painting of the
demon none in conjuring 2 but Annabel
comes home introduces a new painting and
Ed warrants signature style and not just
any painting but what looks like a
rendering of the house featured in the
previous film Annabel creation it's not
a perfect recreation but the placement
of the tree and the remote house are
pretty much unmistakable spooky for
those who don't know the so called
real-life Annabelle doll doesn't look
anything like the eerie porcelain doll
we see in the films in fact the real
thing looks downright goofy it's just a
Raggedy Ann doll
[Music]
the story behind it is essentially the
same although no doubt embellished for
the silver screen some girl got the doll
weird stuff started happening and the
Warrens eventually stepped in to save
the day
Annabelle comes home did pay a little
bit of fanservice to the real doll in
the form of a quick clip of a game show
on the TV don't blink and you'll see a
contestant winning a classic Raggedy Ann
it's not unusual for the people behind
the scenes of a film to slip their names
into some text on screen
Annabelle comes home is no different
during the scene at Judi school Judi
inexplicably stops to stare at the bust
of the school's namesake father Michael
Thomas Morrissey the name doesn't have
any connection to the conjuring universe
or any of the Warrens investigations but
it does bear more than a passing
resemblance to Annabelle comes home
executive producer Michelle Morrissey
coincidence in the conjuring universe
there are no coincidences only spin-offs
get ready for the conjuring eight busted
coming to theaters in 2027 check out one
of our newest videos right here Plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]